the Joe Rogan experience another big
eye-opener for what's kept from us at
one point in 2011 I had a researcher at
the Washington Post a woman there who
has been there for years I could get
myself in trouble for this - I won't say
her name but anyway she's very
well-known and she's their intelligence
researcher she works with all of the
reporters at the post on intelligence
stories national security stories and
she had a someone at the CIA in their
information department who would confirm
or deny stuff with her and she said I
completely trust these people I've been
working with them for 10 years I'll ask
them about Jolley west and see what they
have on them and I said all right before
you ask them don't tell them because she
had the documents I'd share them with
her don't tell them what I have proving
that he was part of the MKULTRA just say
you're working with an author on a book
who wants to know whether they're
because I already done a request and I
got a we could neither confirm nor deny
yeah and she said they don't they'll
tell me the truth like they're not gonna
give me an either confirm or deny we'll
just say we have something and we can't
tell you if we can or we have nothing
but we'll get the truth to see what they
have so a week later she lets me know
and she said they said there's nothing
he never participated in the program
there's no record and I go well I don't
want to say her name I go well I don't
think he should be using them anymore
because they're not reliable and you
know that because you've seen the
documents so she had to rethink that I
don't know you know what she did after
well that's that's the way they can
embed themselves with reporters by
letting these other things yeah I'm your
friend
look I'll tell you the truth right okay
this is it's a complicated world we're
out there we're gonna keep people safe
sometimes we got to crack a few eggs to
make an omelet
right don't worry I'll let you know I
mean I'm your friend
they don't worry if there's some
wackiness yeah yeah yeah that's
hilarious yeah and then I said to her
ask about reef Woodson we haven't even
discussed Reed Woodson
he's the guy that claimed to it he had
infiltrated the Manson fan
we haven't gone to that chapter no no no
is that after 11:00 well how many
chapters are there 13 including the
epilogue yeah yeah yeah I mean there
were a lot of spooky people in and
around the spawn ranch and in and around
the family and this one guy rave whitson
who was a spook and unfortunately was
dead by the time I started people don't
know spook is CIA yeah yeah people don't
know what that means
yeah III didn't know what it meant
before I saw all this I don't know I
mean maybe if I thought about it but I
wasn't interested strange terminology I
know you know well it's like a ghost you
don't say them there's no trace no
record and this guy that's how he lived
and I had found out about him in my
reporting first I got to his attorney
and then to some of his close friends he
lived in Los Angeles and then he
disappeared for months doing undercover
work and he said we never he wouldn't
even tell us who he worked for but his
wife and daughter who were in sweetens
and other people who said it was the CIA
he told before he died in the couple
years before his death three or four of
his closest friends including his
attorney that he had worked on an
operation and he wouldn't tell them who
but he had infiltrated the the Manson
family prior to the murders and it was
his dying regret was he could have
prevented them but didn't he also said
that he was at the crime scene after the
killers had left but before the police
had arrived which was like a 4 or 5 hour
window and I was able to confirm not
that he was there those five hours but
that he was missing and that the police
set up a watch at his father's house who
he was living with to try to figure out
what was going on
he ended up helping Colonel Tate Sharon
Tate's father who left his job in
military intelligence to help the police
in the investigation he even dressed up
like a hippie right he dressed up like a
hippie and so de rêve
and rave was a really hardcore
right-wing guy I mean he was a racist
and his daughter sent me pictures of him
and she said once he died in fact this
is how serious this guy was he Devorah
divorced his wife who was a Swedish
model first he sent her and his infant
daughter back to Sweden from the United
States in 61 because he thought there
was going to be nuclear war and then in
the mid-60s he told his wife he had a
divorce er and he couldn't have any
relationship with his daughter because
his daughter was his only vulnerability
because of the work he did that would be
how they heard even if they lived all
the way in Sweden so the daughter Liza
who I've never met but we started
talking on the phone and she started
sending me materials didn't meet him
until a couple years before his death he
reached out to her said I couldn't have
any relationship with you because of my
work but I want to do that now so he
flew her to Los Angeles introduced her
to all of his friends and after he died
she went to his apartment and went
through his things and found a picture
of him dressed up as a hippie it's in
the book and and I mean it's hard to
tell but it's in a parking lot and the
cars were all like late sixties models
so again this is one of the parts of the
book where I worked so hard to try to
prove a definite link
I interviewed probably 12 or 13 Manson
family members and I'd show them that
picture and they'd say he looked like
any number of guys that that came in and
out of there they come for a day to
screw us the women would say Charlie
would bring guys in and we didn't know
if they were the ones we're providing
drugs or who they were but yeah maybe or
maybe not you know and they were all
high most of the time too
[Applause]